tras varios días en prisión en la cárcel
el chipote de Managua varios familiares
de opositores al gobierno de Daniel
Ortega incluyendo dos francesas
recibieron la noticia que la fiscalía de
ese país centroamericano les había
imputado los cargos de noticias falsas y
de Conspiración y aquí destacamos el
caso de la familia de Javier Álvarez
Zamora declarado opositor pero sin
ninguna afiliación política ni relación
con los medios de comunicación el pasado
13 de septiembre la policía de
nicaragüense irrumpió en su casa en aras
de capturarlo pero este había escapado
horas antes a Costa Rica luego de que lo
hubiesen alertado de su captura de
manera que la policía resolvió arrestar
sin orden judicial a su esposa y a su
hija Yanina y Ana Álvarez of fideos
ambas con ciudadanía doble de Nicaragua
y de Francia así como también arrestaron
a su yerno Félix Royce organismos
internacionales de Derechos Humanos así
como movimientos políticos de oposición
como la unidad nacional
azul y blanco denunciaron que se trata
de una nueva embestida represiva de
parte de Ortega ahora en contra de los
familiares de los opositores familiares
que ahora enfrentarán juicios que les
podrían acarrear años de cárcel y
procesos judiciales
característicos por no contar con
libertades del derecho a la defensa